Film Courage: What is the hardest part of
making a movie and why?
Matt Eskandari, Writer/Director/Producer:
That’s an interesting one.
I think the hardest part about making a film
is the logistics some time.
Those unknowable things that you have no control
over and it doesn’t matter if it’s a hundred
million dollar movie or a $200,000 feature,
there are always going to be things that come
up where do don’t have control over them
right?
And that’s just the nature of what we do,
we are taking a camera, we are pointing it
at real people in real situations and things
in real life…things happen, right?
This actor isn’t available.
Things are going wrong, a light is not working,
the sun is setting and we’re losing our
light.
The sound isn’t…there are loud sounds
here.
There are these unknowable things that are
always coming at you as a director and you
have to be able to filter out the ones that
are going to require your attention and the
ones that you are going to have to move on
from.
I think that’s one of those things that
you can’t really learn, you have to experience
where this has happened to you where the sun
is setting, you have 5 shots to get on your
shot list, “Darn, okay…how do we get this
scene now where the sun is setting?”
And that’s where you’re thinking as an
editor and you are saying okay the previous
scene we did this and there is a scene where
our character walked from here to here…you
know what?
I don’t really need to get this transition.
Let’s just go straight into him, he’s
coming into the room.
It’s being able to be nimble on your feet
and make those adjustments and those cuts
in your head so you don’t lose your whole
day.
So if the producer comes up to you and says
“Did you get your scene?”
You can say confidently “We got this scene.
It cuts together, watch it.”
Film Courage: Is that where the monk-like
stoicism comes into play?
It sounds like it could go either way on this
one?
You could panic.
Matt: Definitely.
Those are the situations where you have to
not let the outside distractions kind of pull
you away from what your goal is as a director
which is you’ve got to sit behind the monitor
and this is one word of advice I got when
I was in film school is ultimately the director
is the ideal audience for films.
When they are sitting behind that monitor
or they are sitting next to the monitor watching
the actors, you’ve got to look at
the next thing.
As a storyteller you are getting yourself
in that position and you are looking at it
at that position.
So being able to turn off everything around
you (all of the noise) from that moment where
you call action until cut and the little in
between and just being able to look at it
as an ideal audience member and just taking
it all in I think is critical to telling your
story.